paris in time lapse
the video paris in motion shows a full
day in the french capital in just two
minutes
the film has made computer scientist
mayul akpovi a sought-after videographer
he doesn't live in paris but in bison
in eastern france
the video was actually an experiment for
me and my family
and then the video really took off on
the internet
lived in paris for four years before
moving to bissell's hall without having
taken even one photograph in paris he
decided to buy a camera and go back to
the capitol
from thousands of photos he cut two
episodes of paris in motion and put them
on the internet
the technology isn't new but the result
was impressive
comes from the west african country of
benin he made the videos to show off his
new homeland
i traveled around for five years
i was in countries like the united
states switzerland benin and in senegal
and i always wanted to take pictures so
that i could show my parents and family
and say for example
look i've been to paris
for his videos he used a combination of
stop-motion and time-lapse techniques
the camera shoots an image every 10
seconds automatically moving slightly
before each shot
the individual photographs are then cut
together
akpovi used six thousand pictures in his
first work bison saw emotion in 2012.
viewers get the impression they're fast
forwarding through an entire day
with the video aesthetics
for me it's most important to pay
attention to colors
there are many different possibilities
when editing pictures
the mood created by the camera movement
almost always gets a good response
works consists of two main steps
at home in bisson
he arranges the photos in a sequence
25 images make up one second of film
then he stabilizes the photos to
eliminate the shaky effects
despite his internet success akpov plans
to stick with computer science
techniques
i keep getting better at video but i
still wouldn't consider myself a
professional i'm an amateur i keep
learning i keep discovering new
techniques and try to use them
he's an amateur with a huge following
more than half a million people have
watched paris in motion online
akpov is not going to rest on his
laurels he now plans to set other major
cities around the globe in motion
you